everybody welcome to Surrey Gardens this
is a zoo slash theme park that geek ISM
and masked Bennett have been working on
for the past couple of months and
they've been releasing episodes every
week on their channels and I highly
recommend to check it out it's a really
interesting and very heavily themed Park
is similar to real-life parks like the
what is that called again
the universal islands of adventure and
Busch Gardens for instance and I'm just
showing off some of these shots to give
you an example of what everything is
looking like so far and a few weeks ago
they addressed me asking me if I was
interested in building a coaster for the
park so I agreed to that and then I
messed up on a couple of things which
I'll try to explain but just before that
I want to say really quickly that I'm
going to be working on a GCI coaster in
this episode as you might be able to
tell from the title and thumbnail of
this video and yeah it's gonna be
interesting to work on one of these
again because they're always quite
difficult to do and therein lies also
the problem that I ran into because
while this was supposed to take about a
week or maybe two it ended up taking way
longer than that and to keek is a man
mask then it i'm terribly sorry for
taking so long to finish this coaster as
for you guys who are watching this right
now you'll find out eventually why this
ended up taking so long
basically jaunty suggested to build a
GCI coaster and I thought that was a
really interesting idea but one of the
things that I've always struggled with
most with these kinds of coasters isn't
even necessarily the track work itself
but really the supports GCI coasters
have a very typical set of supports and
even though I I wasn't really thinking
that I would be going into support work
when I was starting this this build I
eventually decided to start doing that
and by the time I started I wanted to
finish it as well so the majority of
time that I'll be spending on this is
actually going to be support work and
I'm not even going to show off all of it
but still I had to split this into two
videos just because it ended up being so
much video
that I had to cover and there's just so
much work into making this wooden
coaster happen that it ended up taking
me a few weeks to finish this with some
park attacks and planets ooh coming in
between so that explains why it's been
taking so long so without further ado I
do want to move into more fun parts of
this videos because I don't just want to
be a negative Nancy for the whole time
so yeah for one it I'm back to building
a GCI coaster which is something that I
never thought would happen because I've
done this or I've tried this once before
which was a coaster called gambits which
I made a video for over two years ago I
think now which is quite a long time ago
and even though I was super happy with
how it turned out I really only got the
layout done and even that alone took me
a long time so one of the things that I
wanted to do differently this time is to
just try and use long track pieces when
I was building gambits I was using the 4
meter method to try and get an as
accurate as possible GCI coaster in
terms of the shaping of the elements but
that ended up taking so long that
realistically I figured I wouldn't have
time to work on a track like this for
this build so I'm just using the regular
track pieces I did a few test layouts to
see if this could actually work by using
track pieces that are extra long instead
of using really short ones because the
way that these coasters transition I
figured might actually lend itself quite
well to really long track pieces so long
as every track piece transitions into
the next one and at a certain place
either where a curve starts or ends or
where a slope starts or ends which might
not make that much sense as I'm
explaining this and I definitely need to
go into how GCI coasters are made and
what makes them so distinct from other
wooden coasters just to explain this a
little bit better
but yeah I thought it would be possible
to build a decent feeling GCI coaster
using really long track pieces and
honestly without trying to spoil too
much I think it works out alright I'm
pretty happy with the end result i it's
it's not quite as good as gambit was but
that was with the four meter method and
it took me something like ten hours to
get just the layout done on that one so
I I swore to myself to never do that
again and for the record the reason why
gambits never had a follow-up of this
episode is also because of the supports
I gave the file to free the bear and
because I was being a total dick I
didn't want to try the supports myself
so I gave it to him and he started on it
very boldly and I think he spent two
hours supporting just the first drop
before giving up on that one so yeah
that's why I never made a follow up
video on gambits it just wasn't doable
as much as I liked the layouts so anyway
I've talked a bunch about GCI coasters
but there's probably of many people here
who haven't seen the gambits video and
are wondering what the hell all of this
is about
so GCI is a coaster manufacturer it
stands for great coasters international
and they make only wooden coasters and
they're very well known for their
distinct style of wooden coasters and
this is something which is always really
hard to exactly explain but they're
wooden coasters feel like no other
wooden coasters especially to coaster
enthusiasts they are a very popular
manufacturer and they just give really
snappy layouts with very quick
transitions and quick pops of airtime
everywhere which are really fun and
they're also kind of rough but not in a
bad sense they tend to throw you around
but they never really hurts it's all on
purpose and it's all very controlled and
they're absolutely amazing to ride some
of my favorite word coasters are GCI
coasters so you know even though they
are really difficult to build they are
my favorite
to build as well so that's a
double-edged sword if there's any now
the thing that makes them so hard to
build and that makes them in my opinion
maybe even the most difficult coaster to
realistically build in planet coaster
just comes down to the way that they are
designed I don't know the exact methods
which the company uses to design their
layouts but from what I have heard from
some people who have more insider
knowledge is that they tend to design
their coasters not per se in a 3d space
but lay out the map on from a top-down
perspective in 2d beforehand
mapping out where all of the curves and
straight pieces and everything go and
they're doing so they use just mostly
straight pieces and curves and parabolas
to make the transitions between the
curves which are pretty much just parts
of circles and after that is when they
start adding the height differences so
the difference in Heights are sort of
made separately from the curves
themselves so instead of just mapping
out the coaster in the 3d space right
away they just plot down a 2d overview
first and then start raising certain
areas and lowering other areas and also
paying attentions for instance to avoid
having curved tracks going over
different tracks
so whenever the coaster will be going
over another part of the coaster it'll
quickly transition to a straight piece
of track for instance and finally after
that process is when they start ending
the banking and because of this the the
movement of while going upside down or
going from side to side as well as the
movement of banking they're all kind of
separated and it just results in a very
unique feeling layouts and I really
can't talk much about any specific
processes of designing these layouts
beyond that I'm quite a noob when it
comes to that as well
but just know that it results in unique
layouts with a very unique kind of track
shaping and
it you can't just build a GCI coaster by
you know looking at a real one and
trying to sort of follow the general
layouts it all comes down to how the
track transitions from one curve to the
other or how the pack I have the track
just banks and moves in general and it's
it's about as hard to build as it is to
explain for me as you might be able to
tell now let's get into some more fun
stuff because the layouts building for
this episode is pretty much done I
didn't want to finish the whole layout
right away but at this point I wanted to
move into the supports so we're gonna
have a bit of a change of pace here
because well geek ISM and masked bandit
gave me quite a challenge with this
plots because they they gave me these
plots outlined by the white lines which
you can see in the distance in the
background and in the middle of this
plot was an access road which is the
gray area that you can see down below
the coaster track here and whatever I
would do I should keep the access road
clear because this is where all of the
backstage areas are gonna be connected
to the outside world so you know
whatever kind of construction materials
or trucks or stuff you know wants to get
into the other areas of the park they're
gonna have to cross underneath the
wooden coaster here so this was quite a
logistical challenge for one I had to
build the layouts to move around this
road which is why there is a tunnel
right after the first drop going
underneath this road but for the areas
which are going over this road I really
need to figure out a support solution to
try and make this work
now this year at Aiyappa I think it was
which is a very big convention for
coaster manufacturers GCI showcased a
new model which is the very new
generation wooden rollercoaster with
some inversions and steel supports as
well and the coaster they showed off had
black steel supports underneath the lift
Hill which in their case I think was
mostly to allow the lift hill to be
steeper and to be built over
complex track and maybe also to just
look really cool because I do have to
admit it looks pretty interesting but in
my case it is pretty much the only way
in which I can cover the excess Road and
leave this area underneath the lift I'll
open so I'm building the weird steel
support structure underneath the lift
Hill they're not really for aesthetic
purposes but really to keep the area
underneath the lift Hill clear so yeah
it's it's very much there with a purpose
even though I do think it does look
pretty cool I really wasn't sure if this
would work very well after all the
supports are slightly different from the
ones that GCI showed at Aiyappa but I
think it works out quite well and it
definitely gives the coaster a very
unique feeling and for another part of
the layout
I used the the people mover ride to
remove the the track supports underneath
the straight section and then for this
area I need to figure out another way
I'm gonna add some steel beams to that
later and go for more traditional
standard wooden coaster supports now
this is where the really fun parts
begins this is where I get into the
actual supports of the coaster the
regular wooden supports that you'll see
on any GCI coaster and on lower sections
like this it's going to be a bit easier
than on some of the higher sections
basically you get some diagonal beams
sticking out from each of the support
pillars and then between that some more
diagonal beans beans beans
between that you get some more diagonal
beams to connect these it sounds a bit
weird but basically this is what every
TCI coaster does around its curves and
I'm basically just following that
general support structure so this is not
too difficult in any sense I just used
some pictures as reference to see what
kind of support beams the company would
use for different kinds of elements and
generally the supports are very similar
most of the time so it's not too
difficult to try and follow along there
but what does make this very difficult
is that every single beam you place has
to be adjusted to the beams around it
because of course these beams are
following curves they have different
degrees of steepness I guess it's not a
word you know what I mean and I also
need to make sure that all of these
beams actually connect to each other as
well so it's not so much a challenge as
just a very time-consuming thing to make
sure that each of these beams connects
to another one so yeah I also had to
figure out what I would talk about in
this segment because basically from here
on out most of the work is basically
going to be this and when I was doing
this I had to listen to a lot of
podcasts and things trying to keep my
mind sane while I was trying to place
the same beams over and over again so I
don't know if I would recommend doing
something like this doing custom
supports this way is really gonna you
know have an effect on your mental
health eventually I think but for these
videos I thought it might be interesting
if I just talk about some of my favorite
GC eyes and maybe a bit more about the
company in general because it is really
interesting even though I haven't
written many GC eyes myself I think
there's a good chance that even if you
haven't heard of the company or if
you're not that much of a coaster
enthusiasts if you've been on a few
wooden coasters you've probably been on
a GC I at some point for me my favorite
examples in Europe are always Rodin and
Troy in Europa Park and Topher lands
respectively I've only been on Troy
myself but out of any of the traditional
brunnen kosis that I've been on it is by
far my favorite a really good example of
what GCI coasters tend to do and some of
the things in Troy actually return in
this layout so if we look at the first
drop for instance that I'm supporting
here almost every DCI coaster will have
a curving sloped drop like this they
usually don't have a steep straight drop
they usually just have curves everywhere
and the drop is no exception to that
there are a few exceptions like George
in the dragon in the efteling or really
I should say yours in the black I'm a
Dutch person myself but which is also a
really good UCI that I've been on myself
but aside from a few cases most of them
have drops that are almost identical to
the one that I've built here an example
for this drop that I used was actually
El Toro
which is not the El Toro in Six Flags
but the one in flown in Germany which
has a very similar drop and it comes
down into a tunnel underneath a footpath
I think which is the reference that I
used for this drop coming into the
tunnel although the change here is that
after the first drop after this curve
here it dips a little bit lower into
that tunnel so I think that's actually a
really cool element to start off the
ride with so you first get into the main
drop and then right after that you drop
down again down into that tunnel so you
probably catch some air time right after
this drop even if it's not that much and
if it's just for a short amount of time
that is just very typical about GCI
coasters you rarely get very long
sustained airtime but it's usually just
little pops of airtime all throughout
the layouts say that that is one very
typical element about GCI coasters
another one is the station fly through
or is it a station fly by I don't know
either one of those words in any case
what usually happens on these coasters
is that somewhere halfway through the
layouts you have a segment where the
track goes back through the station but
not really this station it just goes
through the station building but a bit
above the actual station with a straight
piece of track which is very cool if
you're on the coaster because you fly
back through the station somewhere
during the middle of the layout which is
really nice but if you're standing in
these stations as I've personally been
able to tell on Troy in toverland they
make a lot of noise it is extremely loud
so yeah it is cool even if it is a bit
uncomfortable if you're standing in the
station itself because the coaster is
passing by
at full speed but yeah it's one of these
typical GCI things that other coaster
manufacturers don't really seem to do as
much and yeah I guess those are the most
typical elements whenever somebody
whenever a coaster enthusiasts would
think of typical elements of a GCI
coaster I think that the station fly
throughs and the curve drops are just
about the most typical things I've also
seen some other quirky elements I've
seen that recent GCI coasters tend to
have two planks on the middle of the
track but to be completely honest I have
no idea what these planks are for
exactly maybe it's just to support the
track a bit more keep it more steady but
really I'm not sure but there's a GCI
called gold striker which is I believe
in California's Great America but I'm
not entirely sure it's in the US in any
case it could yeah I think it's that
Park but yeah it has also two planks
running down the middle of the track for
instance I don't know entirely sure why
that is
I've seen it on some other coaster
manufacturers as well but it seems to be
more of a recent trend but yeah that is
just about it and then there's the
support work which is very typical as
well especially around all of these
curves because they tend to fan out from
the curves and have these diagonal beams
in between all of these squares so the
method that I use to make all of these
supports is basically to use the the
align to scenery tool to align these
planks to the track which is a bit
finicky because you have to align them
using the wooden supports but it's hard
to get that placement it's highly right
and then from those slanted beams I use
the horizontal beams to connect these
together then you get some squares and
then I fill in these squares with
diagonal beams like this and finally add
some vertical beams right in the middle
of that to connect back into the ground
and I'm going to skip ahead a little bit
here actually quite a bit too when all
of these supports are done to show the
last step which is basically to add the
footers
which is the small concrete elements at
the bottom of all of the supports to
hold them up and I really have to thank
feed the bear here because he was
willing to take up some of the supports
of gambits even if for a bit because
going back there I pretty much figured
out what the best way to go about
recreating these supports in planet
coaster was and that is just to take the
arch shapes and color them in just about
the same color as the in-game footers so
these are not quite as detailed as the
in-game ones but I do think they work
better than any of the footers that
we've gotten from the support pieces in
the game it doesn't have to be too
complicated I think it doesn't have to
be super detailed in fact I don't know
if I want it to be detailed because well
the thinking of the park for poor old
geek ISM and masked bandits who have
been waiting for me for weeks to try and
play some wooden beams um no the more I
can keep this low-poly the better it
would also be because this is a park in
the end so I do have to consider how
many pieces that I'm placing here so
it's not too lag of the game too much
even though the pavilion that they've
just built that they've got built from
somebody else who is also a lot of
pieces but for my parts I'm gonna try
and keep this as you know low as I can
get it in terms of the item counts even
though at the end I can already spoil
that it's definitely going to contain
quite a few thousand wooden beams which
are all individually placed almost all
individually placed so yeah again if you
ever think about building a GCI and
planet coaster take my word of advice
don't but if you really really want to
do it I guess some of the tips that I've
given in this video you know to try and
look up real POVs of GCI coasters place
you're shaping on that and do the
supports pretty much the way I have been
doing it in this video and then you
should be golden
now I'm gonna end the video here because
I didn't want the video to become too
long I'm gonna continue it in the next
one which is going to pick up where this
one left off and yeah I hope to see you
guys next time
should be coming out soon I just didn't
want to make a single video of over an
hour long thanks for watching and I hope
to see you next time